when it comes to fighting whatever made
you want to fight if you think back in
your life like
were you did you just kind of at a
certain age start to see like damn i
fight or did it was there something
inside of you like is there a do you
know what it is are you able to get a
look at it whatever that is
my dad's a savage really he's crazy mofo
he's probably still the toughest dude
i've ever seen
and and you know he's just too
loose cannon so i try to take that
and like focus it right into
the the art
of you know being a martial artist a
fighter a boxer
might like i said you know my dad was a
crazy guy did you see him fight growing
up did he fight
um
i heard stories we got in fights with
the neighborhood people
um i saw him make people back down from
fights a lot you know he would get in
people's face like i'll bite your nose
off
in their yard do you know what i'm
saying oh that's in your yard [ __ ] what
are you gonna do yeah
and uh you know
he told me
one time we fought like the whole block
and like i was trying to break it up and
i i was like 13 14 i was just getting
strong and my dad i think he was drunk
and he wanted me to fight
with him with the neighborhood
and um i was trying to break it up and
he got mad at me
and then because he wanted you in it
right he wanted me to want to do it i
guess and like you know i was a kid
though but
uh
and i think he got arrested that night
and he he got out the next day and he
said that the cop he was talking trash
to the cops all night and that they
drove into an alley and they beat him
with their night sticks in the back seat
they opened the back seat start with his
ass
good stories
it probably it probably stung a little
bit that's a good story yeah bro we grew
in my neighborhood people are always
fighting bro and it was a sign of
respect like everybody had their shirts
off all the time dudes walking around
with like those do you ever see to do
with like the cement arms he just walked
he just like uh he the only way he know
how to move he just he never even could
lift his arms up they're just swinging
in front of him we had that kind of dude
we had a guy who went down syndrome bro
but they wouldn't say he had it bro so
he was always out there [ __ ] people
up bro thinking he was in regular
education
we had like uh
dude we had like a whole family with
shirtless bro women all of them the
whole family was shirtless bro always
smoking in their in their house bro the
children were smoking cigarettes
everybody was out on the block back in
the day you know i mean you had your
bicycle you drove to people's houses you
knock on their door yeah and their their
mama answered the door
damn where your son at
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one